look what he has done to this state I
mean he has turned Florida into the
freest
like
Pat there's a reason you're here there's
a reason that every single one of your
employees has huge Smiles on their faces
the checks don't bounce and they live
here in Florida like it it's all
happening here this is it truly it can't
be overstated Florida is the freest
place in the entire world and it is
because it's partly because of trump and
setting up a lot of this stuff and
Florida has had you know an interesting
population over the years but it's
because DeSantis fought the machine
better than anyone over these last
couple years and and beyond that I also
think we just we need a shift we need
it's not about age exactly but we we're
done I think being governed by 80 year
old